Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to this Fff—
I am not farther.
I had meant to start this when I got farther along, but that
Wasn't gonna happen so just bear with me as I get back to where I was
No, stop bouncing!
See, I don't do that bounce. I do not do that bounce.
That bounce is a result of the camera moving and recoiling,
which is the stupidest mechanic I've ever seen in any game
'Cause I can't account for the camera recoil. It's like a—UGH
Never mind. Just never mind.
No, no, nonono
Not like that, not like that, not like that, not like that
buh!
Please! Don't! please!
NOOO!
Do not stand at my grave and cry, I am NOT there. I did not die- Mary Fry
God, the fucking camera bounce, I fucking hate it so much!
To live is to suffer. To survive is to find some meaning in the suffering.
NOOOOO OH MY GOD!
NOOO! I JUST FUCKING GOT BACK UP THERE!
I JUST FUCKING DID THAT!
I'll be right back.
Hang in there
Don't let it get to you—You shut the fuck up, You shut the fuck up, You shut the fuck up, YOU SHUT THE FUCK UP!
You shut the fuck up. I hope you die in a fire
Shut the fuck up.
God stop going around that fucking way
Stop going around!
NOOO!
No no, NONONO!
*gasps of relief*
All this tomfuckery, all this tomfuckery, all of this tomfuckery. I hate it so much
Okay, I hate it so much
no nope nope
Very very gentle very gentle very gentle
My arm is starting to compensate for the rocking,
but I've been rubbing my wrists so much on my mouse pad that it's starting to wear into my—
the meat of my palm it is
This, this game is damaging me in so many ways. I'm gonna have an aneurysm. I'm gonna have a heart attack
My wrists are gonna fall apart
No— ohhh
oh my god, oh my god, oh my god oh my god, Set down, set down!
And then launch! Grab! No! No, okay, just like that
Now, I know, most likely you're watching this on Youtube or Twitch while some dude with 10 million views does it for you.
no, no, NO, NO!
AUUGHH! SHUT UP
Being fed chewed up food. That's culture too.
Shut up
No no no
See that bounce? That bounce, that sudden launch upwards, that's not my doing at all! Just the camera! so I have to accooooommodate
AUGH!
NO!
Life is a mosaic of pleasure and pain.
AGGH!
Grief is an interval between two moments of joy
AUGH!
AAU!
Peace us the interlude between two wars
FFFFUCK!
You have no rose without a thorn, the diligent picker—
This is what drives people to turn into WEREWOLVES!
AUUGH! And that's a choice. Not a curse.
I hate this game so much. This is the worst game
I've ever played in my entire life
I've never hated a game more than this game, and it's fucking pretentious
"Oh, it's hard therefore it's rewarding. "No, it's hard because it's bullshit and you made it that way
So you fucking know, it's bullshit! It's not any wonder of game development
No, you made it bullshit, because you know how to make a game bullshit
You're not a fucking prophet because you made a hard game!
You're back here again, showing patience and then attacking, scraping then flapping and snagging.
You are no saint. You are not better than me, just because you made a bullshit game
You are not!
You are not.
Sorrow is my own yard/ Where the new grass/ flames as it has flamed
Shut up, shut up, shut up, SHUT UP, SHUT UP!
Often before but not/ with the cold fire/ that closes round me this year
I know you know you're making it worse
I know you know you're making it worse with your
Bullshit quotes, from people who were actually contributing to society when they were alive
Which is not you DEVELOPER OF THIS GAME!
You are doing nothing, just the same as I am!
You and I are the same temporary
bullshit piece of human organism, that we all know and hate
We all know
DDYYAAAUUUGGGHH!
AAAAaaaahhh
You piece of shit! If you will not get on this goddamn mountain
Why did you do that? why did you do that?
No—AAUUUH!
I almost fell again, you FUCK!
No, no, why? Why? Why, why when I'm right there? I know what to do, Why?
Fuck! The different rates of acceleration affect your goddamn swing!
Oh my god. I hate it so much
Every part of me. I know how to go up. I do *sharp intake of breath* HHAAA!
I know how to control this piece of shit! I do, I know it, I get it, I get it
I completely and utterly get it! I do, I understand it
Intimately the only thing I can't get is the fucking randomization with the camera!
The speed at which
NOOOO!! I HAD TH—
Shut the fuck up! Shut up, I hate you!
Alright, here I am again! You remember this place? Yeah, I do
So let's just take this... nice and
gently
No! nonono
No, no don't, don't, don't pull in oh
uh! AH!
God! That one was my fault, that one was my fault. That was my fault
I shouldn't have, I shouldn't have tried to go for it—
what— I've— how
Are you—are, are you kidding?
Are,
Are you kidding,  are you—
why?
Why, why?
Why, why that doesn't make any fucking sense as to?
Why the fuck you decided to be a piece of garbage?
No, god-fucking-dammit
I'm not even, I'm not even like anguished anymore. I just expect
Bullshit to be dealt to me
Why?
Oh god, oh god, oh my god.
No, why? Don't! that would have sent me right back down. You piece of shit!
You know that would've! You know that would've! Game, you are frickin' messing with me.
Oh!
Everybody's a winner in your eyes! Every— because everybody loses at the same rate,
Oh fuck you. Fuck you
Okay up here, that's great. This is great. This is great. I'm thinking positive thoughts. I'm thinking about positivity and love
Which I have an abundance of! You know why? 'Cause I'm fuckin' out of my goddamn mind
That's why, that's why, because I'm out of my fucking mind
Why?! oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm here now. That's interesting
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Okay
No, just set down on it! Just set down, there we go.
Ah! Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, AH!
Okay
Nope no no no no no no no no no no! Why are you not?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, no no no no
OHHHH!!!
No, you tricked me you fucking piece of shit
You tricked me! You tricked me into thinking that my hammer was stuck! Fuck you! no! no, not tod—AUGH!
No! NO! OH MY GOD
Of all sad words of tongue or pen,
the saddest are these, "It might've been"
- John Greenleaf Whittier
FUCKING HELL! OH MY GOD, FUCK!
Fuck!
You tricked me, you stuck my goddamn hammer, and you fucking tricked me
You fucking tricked me, you piece of shit game! You piece of shit,
You fucking piece of shit!
How could you fucking do that to me?
Okay.
Calmly and rationally.
But on the off chance that you're playing this, what I'm saying is, trash is disposable, but maybe it doesn't have to be approachable!
What's the feeling like? Are you stressed?
I guess you don't hate it if you've got this far! Feeling frustration is underrated
Fuck you, fuck you and your poetic bullshit
No one cares! No one cares. No! No one cares about anything
Oh, this is supposed to be like a checkpoint, I know! So don't fuck with me. Don't fuck with me
Do not! I will end you! I will end everything there is to know about you!
An orange.A sweet juicy fruit locked inside a bit of peel.
That's not how I feel about a challenge. I only want the bitterness. It's coffee. It's grapefruit. It's licorice
Okay, so I just got to push this orange out of my way first. Get out. Thank you
Oh boy. Oh boy.
So this is a challenge
NOOOO!!!
If you try to please audiences,
Uncritically accepting their tastes, it can only mean that you have no respect for them. —Andrei Tarkovsky
OH MY GOD, that one just hurt so bad! That one just hurt, you fucking asshole!
I'm gonna cry. I'm gonna cry because you're such a piece of shit
That is not what I wanted to do and you fucking know it
You know you piece of shit game!
no!!!
You keep me fucking emotionally compromised. This is what you WANTED?!
This is what you fucking wanted!
That's what you fucking want, you piece. You sa— you sadistic piece of shit
NOOOOO!!!!!!
I'M DONE, I'M DONE, I'M DONE
I'M FUCKING DONE, FUCK YOU, FUCK YOU, FUCK YOU, FUCK YOU, FUCK YOU, FUCK YOU!
FUCK YOU! FUCK YOU! I'M DONE!
I'm fucking done with your bullshit game. I'm done. This is bullshit. I cannot do it. I can't do it
Okay, I'm gonna do it. Okay. I'm gonna keep going, but I have to take like a week off from
From this bullshit because I can't do it
I'm gonna tell the world about how bullshit this game is right now
If you remember this tweet from the past you know that this is the moment
This is the moment that I tweeted this right now
I hate getting over it with every fiber of my being. No game has left me
with more hatred
In my heart
I urge every single person alive
to stay as far away from it as humanly possible,
And I now have a full-blown—full-blown migraine
at the rage
I have felt for this, this demon in the form of a game
There you have it.
I hate you Biffordy Mumblo. Biffordy Fimblebink.
Big fucko!
You are the worst in the world.
Thank you everybody so much for watching
If it makes you feel better
Pretend I love this game. Pretend I'm having a good time
Pretend. Pretend. That's all I can do
And as always, I will see you
In the next video
Bye Bye!
#RAGEFLIP
*Outro Music*
(There's more at the end!)
NOOO!
300% Done